hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ihr seht schon wir befinden uns
mal wieder in Minecraft in der Spongebob
Welt vor einigen Tagen kam mir schon
Teil 1 mit dem lieben castcrafter ich
stehe gerade vor dem Haus von Thaddäus
vor dem Haus von Patrick und vor der
Ananas von Spongebob und heute habe ich
einen anderen special der groko
hat einfach direkt ins Bild reingeknickt
auch mit dem Kroko werde ich heute
genauso wie mit äh Heiko vor ein paar
Tagen auch challenges machen
Herausforderungen unsere Aufgabe wird es
sein heute nicht Patrick und SpongeBob
Patrick unter Deus und SpongeBob und Mrs
rapside den schönsten Tag Ihres Lebens
zu ähm ne bescheren bescheren sondern
heute geht es um Plankton es geht um
Sandy und es geht um misses paar von da
würde ich sagen ne Freundin wenn ihr
Bock habt auf das Spongebob äh Minecraft
DLC schaut einfach mal gerne unten in
die Videobeschreibung für noch mehr
Spongebob Inhalte schaut unbedingt auch
auf dem Spongebob YouTube Kanal vorbei
ganze folgen könnt ihr natürlich auch
Super RTL und Nickelodeon sehen du
kannst mir aber erstmal kurz folgen denn
wir müssen hier hinten zu Plankton hin
und auch ja auch wenn Plankton
tatsächlich ja in der Spongebob Serie so
ein bisschen so der Erzfeind ist so der
Bösewicht wollen wir natürlich lieb wie
wir sind auch Plankton ein wunderschönen
Tag heute bescheren und tatsächlich
sogar den besten Tag seines Lebens
hoffentlichten ich sagte ich glaube auch
wir sind jetzt hier in Planktons Region
angekommen direkt gegenüber von der
großen Krabbe und reden jetzt immer mit
Karin Karen sagt nämlich langsam hat
sich selbst eingesperrt und wir wissen
natürlich alle dass er der schlauste
Mensch der Welt ist allerdings hat er
diesmal tatsächlich nichts angehen
benutzt das heißt wir müssen ihn frei
kriegen natürlich helfen mit Karon dabei
used to the lab maintenance Chef located
behind the Tom okay das heißt wir wissen
ja genau wir müssen außen rum und wir
müssen jetzt irgendwie durch die
Schächte durch und Plankton aus seinem
Gefängnis rausholen was er eigentlich
für Mr krabs gebaut hat um tatsächlich
ihn einzuschrauber oh mein Gott
ja hallo das war's verloren Knopf aha
also immer drin okay wir müssen jetzt
ein bisschen Parcour machen und Plankton
hier befreien eigentlich sollte Mister
krabs hier rein weil Plankton die
Krabbenburger Geheimformel spielen
wollte hast du eine Lieblingsfolge mit
Plankton eigentlich
[Musik]
Spongebob jetzt hier drin hier kommt
immer mit der ist immer dabei aber
wir müssen ja da lang der springt ja
komplett falsch aber der kann auch
weiter springen als wir auch perfekt
meine Lieblingsfolge mit blank dann ist
auf jeden Fall die mit dieser ultra
riesigen super
schmodderblase oder wie die heiße Blende
euch jemand kurzen Ausschnitt ein
[Applaus]
hä was zum sehr seltsam als ob die Blase
im eigenen Willen hätte oder den Willen
eines anderen folgt seht nur
[Musik]
puh Plankton ich wusste es ja ich bin
sie müssen jetzt einfach lange jumpen
oder irgendwas zu tun
hier oh mein Gott als wenn die descript
Game related Sachen hier drin haben was
denkst du da rechts rechts 100% und
jetzt gerade aus
ich bin einfach das Versuchskaninchen ne
so da haben wir es geschafft zu
Spongebob war natürlich die ganze Zeit
schon hier schauen wir mal müssen wir
noch irgendwie was weitermachen hier mit
Parkour hier vorne geht's weiter ja
natürlich help please Plankton schreit
schon guck mal da ist er raus aus wie
ein kleiner Mini Creeper aber erst da
der bedankt sich wir klicken auch mal
auf thanks und äh wir müssen oh nein
hast du auch das Interface ihre Narren
ich bin eingesperrt bei mir ja ja ich
auch aber ich habe bei mir hat sich so
ein Text aufgemacht Training hast du
wahrscheinlich nicht oder
lernen zu lesen ihr dachtet wirklich ich
würde in meiner eigenen Falle tappen das
ist nicht einmal mein wahres Ich dass
ich nur ein Hologramm aber vielen Dank
dass er dich zum besten Tag aller Zeiten
gemacht habe ich könnte mir nicht
Schöneres vorstellen als eure Gesichter
hintergeht dann gefangen zu sehen
schönen Tag noch und ich darf danke
klicken du hast das auf deutsch
wieso habe ich das denn auf Englisch
eine Ewigkeit später ich kann das bei
mir nicht auf Deutsch stellen
ja egal das ist halt auf Englisch was
kannst du eigentlich was muss man denn
jetzt hier machen überhaupt ich glaube
wir müssen irgendwie rauszukommen
einfach mal wild an diesen Hebel
nachdrücken also eine andere Möglichkeit
[Musik]
wir haben es und Plankton ist jetzt hier
eingesperrt oder wie das ist nur ein
Hologramm hat er gesagt ah das ist ein
Hologramm genau der wollte uns
eigentlich nur gefangen halten
einfach nur also ich glaube hinten oder
[Musik]
schau mal an WoW
und das Licht ändert sich
[Musik]
ich würde sagen wir laufen immer über
die drüber wo Licht an ist
ich habe hier ich bin hier und den
letzten
auch gelöst
ey als wenn du hier wirklich Planktons
[Musik]
geheimen Spiegellabyrinth sein
wahrscheinlich ne
wir finden uns gleich nie wieder
[Musik]
das sollte jetzt glaube ich das letzte
Labyrinth sein sonst wären da oben nicht
diese ganzen Leuchte Blöcke glaube ich
mal hier geht's lang guck mal zack
drücken jetzt sind wir wieder hier ist
das jetzt wieder Squid Game mäßig hier
nee guck mal hier sind zwei Schalter
drücken wir den hier einmal und die
Knöpfe verschwinden
sie noch mehr da sind ganz viele okay da
müssen wir jeden Knopf gleich einmal
drücken denke ich mal
[Musik]
ich glaube ja können wir jetzt das Tor
aufmachen nehmen
[Musik]
perfekt ey der der hat aber auch hier im
Gefängnis gebaut guck mal hier geht
schon wieder weiter drück du mal die
beiden linken immer so schnell
nebeneinander dass alle vielleicht auf
einmal leuchten
so so
noch helfen das hier vorne
was ist denn das ist ganz nice da musst
du mit diesen Pistons diesen einen Stein
hier bewegen schauen ah ziehen und
drücken
ach so da mach du das mal würde ich
sagen
20 Sekunden später
[Musik]
einfach mal eben kurz
zu nehmen event
[Musik]
uell auf Wiedersehen Plankton goodbye
wir müssen den Fahrstuhl nehmen und sind
oben und wir haben tatsächlich als
allererstes in diesem Video Plankton und
wunderschönen Tag verbracht ich würde
sagen wir laufen mal rüber zu Sandy geht
raus
als nächstes Freunde seht ihr schon und
der wahre Spongebob Fan wird es direkt
checken wo wir uns gerade befinden es
geht nämlich zu Sandy und ihr seht schon
da vorne sandy hat eine Rakete und Sandy
will zum Mond fliegen das sagt uns auch
hier noch mal ganz kurz wir sind
natürlich ja ein Freund von Spongebob
und wir müssen über fünf Systemen helfen
das Ganze an zu schließen von daher los
geht's meine lieben Freunde es hätte
mich direkt an diese Folge wo äh
SpongeBob und Patrick unbedingt mit
Sandy zum Mond fliegen wollten guck
mal wie geht's Spongebob ja ganz schön
beeindruckend und zufällig weiß ich dass
der Startknopf hier drüben ist
du hast die Rakete gestartet
[Musik]
allerdings du kennst ja aus mit Redstone
ein bisschen ne habe ich gehört ich bin
absoluter Vollprofi und das war gelogen
aber wir kriegen es hin wir schaffen das
schon irgendwie wie gehen wir vor hier
fährt wahrscheinlich warte mal
okay jetzt passiert nichts
ein wie die ganzen Redstone Rätsel hier
machen weil ich glaube sonst dauert das
ein bisschen zu lange
[Musik]
Notebook ist einfach eine timelapse
gerade von ein oder zwei Minuten oder so
wir sind fertig Sandy impress your did
it okay the nice wir müssen den roten
Knopf drücken sagt sie und dann geht's
anscheinend los mit der Rakete gibt's
auch wieder eine Animation casada es ist
so es ist so viel Liebe zum Detail in
diesem ganzen die als hier das habe ich
noch nie erlebt bei irgend einem anderen
DLC in Minecraft
haben wir auch hier zum Besten Tag
geholfen das ging wirklich sehr sehr
flott und jetzt ist Spongebob auch
wieder da klar bei Redstone hat sich
gedrückt und jetzt müssen wir
tatsächlich rüber zumindest paar der
Fahrschule Lehrerin
[Musik]
so Leute wir sind angekommen in der
driving school Park muss ich tatsächlich
auch noch mal lernen vielleicht sollte
ich automatisches waffenbesuch abstatten
allerdings habt ihr gerade schon gesehen
wie riesig diese Map wirklich ist
Spongebob bekommen denn Fall mit dem
Boot hier rüber gefahren aber gut wir
müssen jetzt ein paar auf jeden Fall
helfen wobei es ist paff water terrible
day sagt sie also was sind schrecklicher
Tag wir sollen dir helfen wir sind
natürlich ein Kumpel von Spongebob
misses Paps Boot ist kaputt und sie
braucht Kohle oder Meerjungfrau Mann und
blaubarsch auch am Start äh mir Boot ist
auf jeden Fall kaputt und sie braucht
ganz viel Kohle um das Ding wieder zu
reparieren deswegen müssen wir in diesem
Rennen teilnehmen weil es dort natürlich
einen Hauptpreis gibt und
dementsprechend wie das Ganze einsacken
müssen von daher Kroko setz dich in
deine komische Kajüte da rein du darfst
ehrlich rein doch doch
Spongebob bei dir mit drin das heißt du
hast eigentlich sogar doppelt Gewicht
los geht's vor uns ist auf jeden Fall
also so schnell ich weiß auch nicht ich
habe doppeltes Gewicht deswegen sind wir
nicht langsamer okay die sind ja alle so
fix ach guck mal an den Pfeilen kriegt
man Turbo wenn man dadurch fährt die
jetzt bewusst dass wir dass die erster
werden soll während du mal erster ich
halt alle ab ja okay das ist ein gutes
[Musik]
wir bleiben euch immer kurz ein paar
Szenen von misses paar nicht auf ihr
kennt sie alle also der
fahrschullehrerin die hier sich mal
aufplustert wenn sie sich aufregt ne
Tochter davon an die ist gar nicht die
Tochter vermisst Mistress Tochter ist ja
Perla aber irgendwie oh moment men in
bornin also meerjungfern gewonnen wir
nicht wir müssen noch mal fahren aber
wir werden euch erstmal ein paar Szenen
von Mrs Puff ein und was machst du als
nächstes
nein nein kein Vollgas voll geil nein
nein bitte kein Folge okay voll geil
[Musik]
oh
Spongebob durchgefallen
ja guck mal da oben drauf
happy ja sie hat ein neues sie hat ein
neues Boot bekommen und jetzt noch mit
dem Spongebob reden Spongebob sagen we
did it remanager help everyone okay also
wir haben jedem heute geholfen das heißt
jetzt 12 Sekunden später wird es
anscheinend eine richtig große Party
geben die freuen sich wir haben alles
geschafft wir haben in den letzten Video
drei äh challenges hingekriegt drei
Herausforderungen gemeistert und auch in
diesem Video drei Herausforderungen die
Leute die Bewohner von Bikini Bottom
sind happy wir sind happy und Leute wenn
ihr auch happy sein wollt bzw auf den
Leuten helfen wollt dann check mal die
Videobeschreibung ab da findet ihr einen
Download Link für das Spongebob DLC das
könnt ihr euch dort in Minecraft ein
Marktplatz runterladen könnt euch das
kaufen und dann hier auch so ein
bisschen rum spielen guck mal der Kroko
geht da vorne richtig ab wenn ihr Coco
übrigens äh mal auf Youtube abonnieren
wollt oder meine Videos angucken wollt
findet ihr natürlich selbstverständlich
auch unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt
wenn es euch gefallen hat das gerne
einen Daumen hoch unter diesem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen für noch mehr
Spongebob Inhalte schaut unbedingt auf
dem SPON YouTube Kanal vorbei ganze
folgen könnt ihr natürlich auch Super
RTL und Nickelodeon sehen und jetzt will
ich sagen Kroko hast du die letzten vier
Worte es war mir eine Ehre es hat Spaß
gemacht
das waren mehr als vier Worte aber gut
haut rein tschüss